uh the subject for this evening i'll
just give it a title
i am his what did i say
i
am his
good evening everyone
uh before we have our speaker this
evening
we have tomorrow our canvassers are
leaving our college students are leaving
for canvassing and typically we have a
special dedicatory prayer for them
before they head out
and we wanted to do that
this evening
and so
i just wanted to
reflect with you for a few moments
before we have our prayer
canvassing changed my life
i came here to this school
and it was my junior year i started
canvassing here with eugene pruitt
and it was
20 hours a week continuously and every
break in between
and we're told that the canvassing work
is going to be
coupled with the medical missionary work
and go on to the close of probation
this is frontline's work
and
ellen white also indicates that it's the
highest
form
of missionary service
you're his representatives
there's people i've met in the field
that i believe sincerely are going to be
in the kingdom
and i can't tell you how many doors i've
knocked on my my knuckles
got callouses on them
and i could tell you stories
uh and it's framed my life to this point
i i believe i wouldn't be in ministry
today
if it wasn't for the canvassing work
taught me people skills
taught me to have thick skin
to love people
despite the way that they were treating
me
and ellen white indicates that
some people
will never pick up a bible
don't have the privilege of living in a
place like this
to even see god through natural
revelation in nature
and she
says that for some people
you're the only jesus
that they're ever going to see
a living epistle
known and read of all men
and so when you go to that door
i pray that you're prayed up
amen
because when they open it
that might be their only chance before
revelation closes
and that jesus shine through you amen by
his grace as you go there the lord will
take care of your finances
seek first the kingdom of god and his
righteousness
all these things will be added unto you
you make souls in his kingdom number one
god owns a cattle on a thousand hills
he's going to take care of you i have no
doubt about that
so tonight
let's lay it on the altar amen by his
grace let's make it about souls in his
kingdom his cause
and just look around us
we're hearing the footsteps of
approaching god
the second coming is near
and the lord
has sent each one of you is sending each
one of you into the field tomorrow
and so
i know that we're not all here i'm
looking out and
but for those that are here the college
students
we want to have a special
dedicatory prayer
this evening to dedicate this canvassing
program to the lord jesus each one of
the leaders the students
and that the lord would
go before you to prepare the hearts of
the individuals that you're going to be
meeting
and it's spiritual warfare you know that
you're like the marines going into the
field
we wrestle not against flesh and blood
but against principalities of powers
spiritual wickedness in high places
the lord will be with you he'll be your
strength and shield
and i want to invite you to come up here
if you're canvassing college students
come on up here to the front
even if you're a college student and
whatever reason you're
i know some of you have medical
conditions you're not able to go but
you're part of the team so come on up
front too
and
if you're not able to join us this time
you i know that your heart's really with
us so i want to invite you to come up
here
and and pray uh those of you that are
sitting down i want to invite you to to
pray in your hearts as we as we pray for
the
holy spirit to
attend us here this evening and pastor
skeet
uh if you wouldn't mind coming up here
as well and uh we'll have two prayers
i'll pray and then we'll have pastor
randy skeet
pray a prayer of dedication for you
as well
my heart is with you
i know what it's like
um
and i pray that this canvassing program
um would be by his grace the best one
we've ever had
not just in terms of sales the lord will
take care of that but in terms of divine
appointments
and people that you meet
and and pray that god drops you off
that you're dropped off on the right
street for that right person that you
you have a unique connection with
so let's pray let's kneel together let's
all kneel together
and i'll pray and i'll ask pastor skeet
too
to close
our father and our god
we are sending these canvassers
recognizing that when you said go ye it
meant go me
lord we recognize that for many
individuals this may be their
last chance at salvation we don't know
the destiny of earth's teeming
multitudes
is about to be decided
and i pray for every canvasser
lord you know their hearts you know
their struggles
fears burdens
we thank you that your biddings are
enablings
that within every command is the promise
that it's not the capabilities that we
possess or ever will possess that will
give us success it is what god can do
for us
and i thank you for these young people
i pray that you would help them by your
grace to stand for the right of the
heavens fall to be as true to duty as
the compass needle is to the north pole
that they would rather die than dishonor
their maker
may their faces be like a flint
may they not be moved
may you put their your words in their
mouth
may you inspire them
may they shine for your glory and for
your honor
and we pray for a rich harvest of souls
in your kingdom
that we may not recognize until we stand
on the sea of glass
restored back to the image of god lord
this is eternal time
and i pray for the power of the holy
spirit to descend on them this evening
that you grant to them every gift the
fruit of the spirit
so that men may know
at every door
that these young people
have been with jesus
bless and keep them to that end for we
ask these things in the precious name of
jesus christ
amen
our father in heaven we come into your
presence to thank you dear god
for calling us to do the work of the
gospel
we thank you today god that you have
told us
the angel of the lord in campeth round
about them that fear him
and deliver of them
are they not all ministering spirits
sent forth to minister to them
which shall be heirs of salvation
as your young sons and young daughters
prepare to hit the field
to do this noble work
help them to believe that unseen angels
will be with them
not to make the way necessarily easy
but to assist them in triumphing over
every challenge that comes
even more so let the spirit go ahead of
them
and touch the hearts of those upon whose
doors they will knock
help them to understand that god this
exercise is not primarily a financial
one
it is a spiritual adventure
for those to whom they'll speak and for
their own
development and so i ask you in the name
of jesus christ a name you never resist
put your words
in their mouths their god
let them say the right things
put courage in their hearts
let them personalize psalm 118 verse 6
the lord is on my side
father let one be a support to the other
so that when the campaign campaign is
all over everyone will look back and see
how god has moved in that person's life
and has also blessed materially
so we commit them to you their god
wrap your arms around them father
and let them by faith
hear the footsteps of the angels walking
with them
and may souls be one to your kingdom
because of the youthful and upright
witness
bless them in every way
make them a blessing bless this
institution i pray
in jesus name
amen
god bless you
oh praise the lord all the nations
praise him holy people
for his merciful kindness is great
toward us and the truth of the lord
endureth forever
praise ye the lord god is good
come on god is good
and all the time
yes psalm 100 verse 5 for the lord is
good
psalm 145 verse 17 the lord is righteous
in all his ways
and holy in all his works meaning god
never does
and cannot do anything wrong
the lord is righteous
in all his ways
and holy
in all his works god is always good
when he blesses us
he's good
when he punishes us come on he's good
when he answers our prayers he's good
when he says no
he's good
god
is always good
and i love god and i also like to say i
like god
he's a very nice person god has never
done me anything wrong
in my entire life
he has never done me
anything wrong
all my blessings have come from god
all my problems i brought on myself
by my stupid decisions so god
has never
done me
anything wrong and so i praise his name
and i thank him for being such a sweet
god and i look forward if i'm faithful
to see god how
faced don't you want to see god
just to see god this is the mighty god
the father to see him of whom the bible
says no man have seen god at any time
you and i revelation 22 verse 4 we shall
see him
people have seen christ
not god
and i want to see god i really do
and so i want to see moses
talk to him a little bit
i want to see david
chat with him
father abraham
i want to see
jonah
chat with him about his
submarine experience
i want to see mary what was it like to
give birth to god
how you didn't hear me
what was it like to breastfeed god dear
change god's diapers are you listening
to me
ah you're not listening you're laughing
at me i want to talk to sister mary
i want to talk to joseph what was it
like when your wife was pregnant and you
had nothing to do with it
men killed for that are you following me
i want to talk to paul
all those journeys you know when i
became an adventist and i began to study
the bible i was attracted to paul
because of all his travels
and i said lord
can you guess what i told god i'd like
to do that
and the lord when he saw the time was
right he has permitted me to do that
visit at least 51 countries i believe
and all six habited continents
but i uh i want to see god i want to
have a place in his kingdom and the only
person who can keep me out
is me
the only person who can keep you out of
god's kingdom
is you
not satan
i don't i don't want to defend satan but
satan cannot make you sin
notice the temptation if thou be the son
of god command that these stones be made
bread temptation is an invitation to
which you and i has to rsvp
you know what that is
all right too often we say yes
satan cannot make me sin god cannot
force me to do what's right
the choice is mine
knowing not that the whom you yield
yourselves servants to obey his servants
here to whom you obey whether you've
sinned to death of obedience unto
righteousness you and i must serve
someone the only choice is whom will i
serve
not will i serve that's inevitable it is
whom will i serve may you always make
the decision
to serve god well that's not my message
let me get to it i only have well all i
need is half an hour
i have to leave very early in the
morning my flight leaves at seven it's a
two-hour drive to the airport so you
know how early
i have to rise
so when i'm done here if you don't look
around if you look around and see me
gone
just listen carefully you'll hear a loud
noise that's me snoring all right
i have no particular well
the subject for this evening i'll just
give it a title
i am his what did i say
i
am his
let me make sure this is off
it's dead
are yours dead as well
unless you have a need for them
otherwise
make sure they're off
favor number two
while i'm speaking pray for me and say
lord
put your words in that man's mouth
jeremiah chapter 1 verse 9 then the lord
put forth his hand and touch my mouth
and the lord said unto me behold i have
put my words in thy mouth i want to
speak god's words here is what jesus
said about god's words the words that i
speak unto you they are spirit and their
life he did not say that about my words
favor number three think as you listen
isaiah 1 18 come now let us do what
reason together set the lord it is
astonishing that god is always the one
making the first move when adam sinned
god made the first move when cain killed
abel god made the first move he's always
the one because a carnal person cannot
make the first move towards god
you don't believe me go to romans 3
quickly
this is a mini sermon prior to the big
one
which would be small
a big mini sermon
do you have romans chapter 3
ah all right the front row has it
the back row is still in the old
testament looking for romans
do you have it now
all right romans chapter 3 let's read
from verse 10 let me pray first father
as we read briefly and likeness i pray
in jesus name amen what does that say
but as it is written what
there's none righteous no not one keep
reading there's none that
understand it there's none that seeketh
after god
the carnal nature does not naturally
seek god it may seek church
not god
christ told
zacchaeus luke 19 verse 10 the son of
man is come to do what
seek
and to save why does he have to seek
because the sinner does not seek god of
his own a divine power must gently push
him towards that's the power of the
spirit and even he can resist that
and so god is the one who seeks god is
the one who moves first
and so i ask you to reason with me pray
for me and preserve reverence let's pray
our father in heaven this is the last
presentation for this weekend
grant me your spirit
give to me the humility of christ
give me the boldness of christ
and keep me ever conscious that i to am
a sinner
bless your young sons and daughters
their god beautiful young people
you love them in a way that they do not
understand
you desire to save them satan desires to
destroy them
the bible says in luke 19 verse 10 the
son of man has come to seek and to save
the bible says in first peter chapter 5
verse 8 be sober be vigilant because
your adversary the devil as a roaring
lion walketh about seeking whom so the
devil seeks and you seek
who catches us is entirely up to us
let these young men and young women
allow you to catch them every day now
father tell me what to say
and how to say it i pray
in jesus name
amen
genesis 1 reading verse 1 our subject i
am his 7 26 i'll release you before 8.
genesis 1 1 there's no need to turn the
bible
tell me what it says
in the beginning god created the heaven
and the earth now here's some quizzes
way over there what was made on the
first day too slow this side
too slow that side light
what was made on the second day
too slow that side
the firmament
what was made on the third day
and the water in the dry land and
vegetation
i come back to you in mercy what was
mirror on the fourth day
what
sun moon and stars fifth day
fifth day
birds and fish sixth day
land animals and mankind
adam and eve
were the last
of god's creation
god does nothing by accident
he deliberately
made adam and eve last and we tend to
think well they were the crowning act of
his creation and indeed there were but
there's another reality we must consider
adam when he opened his eyes
eve when she opened her eyes could not
claim to have made one blade of grass
everything was already made are you with
me
when you think of that and then you
listen to god's words to job where was
thou when i laid the foundations of the
earth where were you you were nowhere
around he could have said to adam where
were you when i made the sun
nowhere where were you when i made
vegetation nowhere i'm trying to drive
home the point that creation is god's
work and god's word as a matter of fact
the hebrew word for create is only
applied to god
adam was not an assistant creator
even when his wife was made he was in a
deep sleep
god could have said adam watch this
as he made eve
in a deep sleep when eve was made when
adam was made eve had not yet existed
what am i trying to tell you
everything in heaven and earth
rightfully belongs
to god
on the basis of what
creation
now listen to these words from ellen
white education page 137 paragraph four
listen very carefully particularly if
you have a business
that which lies at the foundation
of business integrity
and true success
is the recognition of god's ownership
the creator of all things he is the
original proprietor all that we have is
a trust from him because we are his
stewards
all that we have is a trust from him to
be used in accordance with his will or
in accordance with his directions all
that we see belongs to god let the bible
confirm that claim
go to psalm 24.
our subject i am his
psalm 24 let's read verse one
i know you're familiar with that verse
the earth is the lord's
and the fullness thereof the world and
they that dwell therein
notice the elements of that verse
the earth
is the lord's
and the
fullness thereof
the world
and they that dwell therein
everything on earth rightfully belongs
to god
why because he is the creator
let's go to psalm
we read from verse 10.
psalm 50 reading from verse 10.
you have that
what is that saying
for every beast of the forest is mine
and the cattle upon a thousand hills i
know all the fowls of the mountain and
the wild beasts of the field are mine
read verse 12.
if i were hungry come on i would not
tell the why
for the world is mine and the fullness
thereof this is not symbolic language
this is literal by the way uh don't put
the verses on the screen i want my
people to find them who's the nice
person putting verses on the screens
okay you can put an end to that
outreach and just leave the screen black
i want you to go to the bible open the
bible and find the texts
let me pause who can recite genesis
revelation
all 66 books
too many screens
too many of these who can recite genesis
to revelation
all 66 books in order
come
you did not understand my question my
fault entirely as usual
only the books
not every word only the books
it's cause we learned a song in school
so
uh genesis exodus leviticus numbers
deuteronomy joshua judges ruth first and
second samuel first and second kings
first and second chronicles ezra
nehemiah esther jobs psalms proverbs
ecclesiastics song solomon isaiah
jeremiah lamentations ezekiel daniel
hosea joel amos obadiah jonah micah
matthew mark luke john
acts romans first corinthians 2
corinthians galatians ephesians
philippians colossians thessalonians 1
and 2 first timothy 2nd timmy the
titus
philemon
hebrews james first and second peter
first second john third john jude of
revelation amen
say amen for that scholar
wherever i go i ask that question i find
very few hands you see when you have a
electronic device you don't need to
memorize the books of the bible
but let me tell you something don't
settle for anything that minimizes the
use of your mind
use this
are you following me and the more you
use it the stronger it becomes
i'm not a medical doctor but my
prescription to avoid alzheimer's is to
keep this in your head
that's my medication keep this in your
head keep a strong mind the point i'm
trying to make everything belongs to god
go to first chronicles 29 let's read
verse 14.
our subject i am his
first chronicles 29 reading verse 14.
are you there
read this is david speaking what does
the verse say read with me but who am i
and what is my people that we should be
able to offer so willingly after this
sort read on nice and loud for all
things come of thee finish the verse
and of thine own have we given thee even
when you and i returned the tithe
we're giving god was his when we return
the offering we're giving god's was his
whatever is left in our pocket still
belongs to god
i thought i'd get an amen for that
listen to me again
if you earn a hundred dollars
your tithe is ten dollars if you make
your tithe you're you're offering ten
dollars okay fine the eighty dollars
still belong to god
you're choking on that amen the 80
dollars still belong to god why the
earth is the lord's and the fullness
thereof many economies are based on the
gold standard haggai 2 verse 8 the
silver is mine and the gold is my when
god made the earth genesis 2 from verse
10 and the river went out of eden to
water the garden and from thence it was
parted and became into four heads the
name of the first is paisan that is it
which going towards the land of havilah
where there is gold
god made gold
and if you base an economy on gold the
money rightfully belongs to god
your health belongs to god
your physical body belongs to god go to
exodus chapter four
who has it who has exodus four
all right someone from the right
in the bible the right side is the side
of power and victory
we want comment on the left
you have exodus chapter four
let's read from verse 10. god calls
moses to speak to pharaoh
do you have her stand what does that
verse say
and moses said unto the lord o my lord i
am not eloquent neither here to for nor
since thou hast spoken to thy servant
finish that verse but i am slow of
speech and of a slow tongue i've got a
problem
fine says god listen to verse 11. what
does god say and the lord said
who hath made man's mouth
stop
let's extend that anatomical list
who have made man's
mouth who have made mans
eyes who have made mans
kneecaps who have made man's ears who
have made mans elbow who have made man's
heart who has mid-man's kidneys with
made man's ribs god made everything so
when god said to moses who made the
mouth
if you've got a problem with your mouth
i made the mouth
i can fix it
i made a heart i can fix it
the
go to first corinthians 6.
i ask you to read and you don't read i
can hardly hear you
perhaps you'll surprise me this time
or maybe i ask you to come to the mic
reading the bible is a joy
you have first corinthians
read verse 15 for me
king james version read it nice and
clear what does that verse say
no you're not
your body is what
the members of christ keep reading shall
i then what
take the members of christ come on and
make them
now you know what a harlot is
paul says
he's talking to men you see the men in
that church had a problem with
prostitutes
paul is saying you can't use your
physical body
to engage in that act
because your physical body come on
belongs to christ
i am not speaking symbolically
the same way god said who made man's
mouth he could say that about everything
on your body
and i'm trying to be polite are you
following me
it belongs to god
then you can't use it any way you like
i need to say i am not
speaking symbolically
this hand belongs to god
when the bible says whether therefore
you eat or drink or whatsoever you do do
all to the glory of god that applies to
the marital bedroom
i keep losing you
you look at me as though you're sleeping
with your eyes open
it applies to the marital bedroom
your body belongs to god
if that's the case your intellect
belongs to god
historical sketches page 285 paragraph
four you may write that down historical
sketches
what page should i say
285 what paragraph four
have you written it down
here's what it says
every youth
should be impressed with the fact
that he's not his own he or she that his
strength his time his talents belong to
god
my lovely sister is saying where is she
she sang this morning where is
she oh there you are
that voice belongs to god
and you can't take it to hollywood and
make it a commercial thing it belongs to
god
where's my brother moses who was helping
with audio visual when i was doing a
there's moses where is he
where's dr moses there he is
that skill belongs to god
handel
has a skill he's back there his ability
finish my words
belong to god
i am not
speaking symbolically
your talents your abilities belong to
god
your youth belongs to god
this mind as i said belongs to god
what's our subject
i'm his
if this is the case and god is the
rightful owner of all you have your
first impulse your first desire your
highest aim should be to use what you
have been trusted with
how
for the glory of god
when you go campusing beginning tomorrow
the day after
when you knock on the door don't and
someone comes to the door don't see just
a potential
sale
see a
potential soul
i was in zimbabwe many years ago about a
few five
and
somebody came to my room
two men
and they had a business
and i said to them they wanted me to
discuss the business and pray for it
when people walk into your business
you must discipline yourself not to see
customers
but to see potential
souls
as dr shin said when you do that god
takes care of the rest
let the bible show you what i mean go to
exodus 31 39 not exodus sorry genesis 39
let me pray again father as i continue
this brief message it won't last much
longer continue to speak through me to
god in the name of jesus christ i pray
amen genesis 39.
and joseph was brought down to egypt and
potiphar an officer of pharaoh captain
of the guard bought him off the hands of
the ishmaelites which had brought him
down feather and the lord was with
joseph finished verse 2 and he was
and he was in the house of his master
thee
all right the lord was with joseph he
was a prosperous man
read verse 3 for me now nice and loud
and his master saw keep going
now the lord was with him now stop
take a deep breath
finish that verse
and that the lord
made all that he did to prosper now wait
a minute stop
everyone wants results am i right
if in business your results profits if
your school your results grades listen
to verse three
his master's saw
based on verse two tell me something
about the master and his religion
talk about his religion
he was pagan
the egyptians were polyistic they
worshipped the hawk they worshipped the
cat they worshiped the snake they
worshipped the crocodile they worshiped
the nile river they worshiped everything
that existed
the egyptian is contrasted with joseph
he was in the house of his master the
egyptian
he was in a non-hebrew environment and
despite that his master
saw
that the lord was with him
that the lord made all that he did
to prosper
i want to tell you this
when you recognize that god is the
rightful owner of your life and your
talents and your skills the rightful
honor the only thing you and i
rightfully own are our sins and god
wants them
when you recognize that and you live
with the consciousness i belong to god
my gifts belong to god it is god that
guarantees results
and so jesus christ who never lied
he tells us in matthew 6 33
seek ye come on
first
what the kingdom of god come on and his
righteousness finish the verse
all these things shall be added
not if you ask
added
the christians who believe i have to ask
god for food why
the egyptians the israelites ask god for
food he sent it
when you belong to god god is
responsible for you from a to z
what you've got to be careful is let me
be faithful to god let god worry about
food i'll worry about faithfulness and
staying with him his master saw that the
lord was with him your unsaved friends
must see that you're christian
you know the word christian came from
not from the christians
the unbelievers called them christians
because they saw and observed their
whole lives centered around what
christ so they called them christians
the lord wants to be responsible for the
results in your life but your motto must
be i
am his
listen to christ praying go to john 17.
listen to the prayer of christ and i'll
let you go in about five minutes 7 45.
john 17 christ is praying listen to
verse 9 and verse 10.
do you have those two verses
not yet
read with me
i pray for them meaning the disciples i
pray not for the world but for them
which thou has given me for they are
thine now read verse 10.
all mine are thine and thine are mine
christ says whatever i have
belongs to the father
whatever he has come on belongs to me
and when you are connected to christ
whatever christ has
is yours
as he sees you have need go to verse 21
or verse 23 of john 17 christ is still
praying what does that verse say
i in them and thou in me that they made
me be perfect in one stop listen again
microscopically i
in them who's the them
the disciples
i in them keep reading
that who's thou
the father in me now if the father is in
christ
and christ is in you what do you have
father and the son
but the father and the son are always
represented by
the holy spirit
so whom do you have
father
son and holy now you tell me how can you
go wrong
when you are in dwelt
by father
son
and holy spirit
and wherever they are the angels are
right close by the angels don't indwell
you they are right next because the f
the angels are always where the trinity
members are
you look at the the sanctuary here's the
mercy seat and the two angels on either
side the cherubim they were built from
the same piece of gold the mercy seat
was made from are you listening to me
let me say it again they were made from
the same piece of gold meaning they had
an intimate connection with god's work
salvation and administering the universe
wherever they are the angels are right
there
that's who you have when you go out
tomorrow on monday
to canvas that's who we have in our
day-to-day duties whatever those duties
may be and there is no age restriction
my listening friend
i want you to live with the
consciousness that you belong to god
go to matthew 5 quickly matthew 5.
let's read verse 45.
matthew 5 reading from verse 45. i want
you to see something there
you have that
what does that say that ye may be the
children of your father come on
which is in heaven for he maketh his son
to rise on the evil and the good and
sendeth rain is also his reign he maketh
his son now what can live on the earth
without sunlight
nothing
the sun is his
he gives it to us
or he allows us to be blessed by the
sun's ministry
it is god's
it is god that sends the rain
it is god that keeps the wind blowing
his he maketh his wind to blow and his
waters to flow it is all god
because of christ
god can make these blessings available
to us as otherwise said every loaf of
bread is stamped with the cross of
calvary every water spring has calvary
written on it
i am his
you belong to god
only you can take you out of god's hands
and tonight i'm asking you in the name
of jesus
live day to day with the recognition
you belong to god
consequently you cannot eat whatever you
like
if i loaned you my car
you'll take better care of my car than
you do of yours because you know you
have to give an account to me
this belongs to god
what we put into it
what we put on it
where we take it how we use it all this
must be done with the consciousness this
belongs to god this mind what will i
fill it with movies
or the word of god
because the mind was given to us to
appreciate god it's a it's terrible to
god i would imagine god has given a mind
to people sharp minds they go to college
and study and get degrees that say
there's no god
in other words god gives you a mind you
go to college and you have to get a
degree and your thesis is there's no god
with the mind that god gave you don't do
that
use your life
use your mind
use your body
use your abilities for christ why what's
your title because i
am his you literally belong to god
how many of you will say with me father
help me by your indwelling spirit to
live with the consciousness
that i belong to you can i see your
right hand
stand up with me
you are not too young to be faithful to
god
faithfulness does not apply to all the
people it applies to anyone
josiah was faithful at eight years old
christ was faithful at 12.
it is not a reserve for the elderly
faithfulness has no age restrictions
anyone who has the knowledge of right
and wrong can choose to be faithful to
god and god wants you
the bible says in uh proverbs 12
ecclesiastes 12 1 remember now thy
creator when in the days of that you i
was a catholic many years ago as a boy
and the catholics had to sing i'll
paraphrase the saying
give me a child
for the first seven years
i'll give you a catholic for life
loy tells us 50
of a child's character is determined by
the age of three
that's why the devil wants you
young
but god also wants you
young you see
if a tree is growing in its youth you
can bend it shape it do whatever you
like
you have not accumulated a history of
sins like barnacles on a whale's back or
turtle shell that god has decided to
scrape off from an old man like myself
clean fixing you up for god is easy
you take someone who's lived 50 60 years
of sin then god has to perspire to fix
him up
so this is the best time
to give yourself to god when the
problems are not that big when the
habits are not that deeply rooted when
it's easier for god to fix it
and make you a jewel that he can hold it
before the world and say look
what i can do to surrender soul
heads bowed eyes closed father in heaven
we thank you for your word we thank you
to god you are the rightful owner of the
universe and on a personal basis you
literally and legally own us because of
creation
father we accept this teaching biblical
as it is and we humble ourselves before
you father and we renew our surrender to
you
we want to live with the unsleeping
consciousness
i
am his
my body
is his
my mind is his
my talents are his
they god
help us to know that when we live this
way you guarantee results in our lives
bless every young person father first
then bless the rest of us
again i ask you go with the canvas as
god let them literally sense your
presence with them
let them go from one door to the next
knowing that the blessing they did not
receive at this door or the next may be
waiting for them at the last door they
knock on that day
because you have to try them
protect them from harm and danger they
god
watch over us tonight
and father if one of us sleeps tonight
may we sleep in jesus
thank you for loving us when you come
save us there god save us i pray
in jesus name let god's people say amen
and amen
god bless you god bless in all that you
do
thank you pastor skeet and
we want to say a special word of prayer
with you for you before you leave we
know you got an early flight and
i thought it fitting
you quoted ellen white where she says
the creative power is within the word of
god and
i thought we could sing psalm 51 as our
closing song and then we'll say a prayer
for you and
send you on your way
create in me a clean
heart oh
god and renew our right spirit within me
create in me a
clean oh
god
and renew our right spirit within me
cast me not away
from thy
presence o lord
and take not thy holy spirit from me
restore
unto me
the joy of thy salvation
and renew our right spirit within me
father nevin
we have been
blessed this weekend
we have been inspired
to live by every word that proceeds from
the mouth of god
we pray that the word of god would not
be
a part of our lives
but that it would be our lives
for as you said your words are spirit
they are life
and father we pray that you would help
the word
to become the subject of our meditation
day
and night
we pray that you would help us to hide
the word of god in our hearts that we
might not sin against you
we pray that every day
the creative power which is in the word
of god
would create in us a new heart and renew
in us
a right spirit
help us by your great grace
we pray that you'd bless you
your manservant today
may you return to a hundredfold
of what he's invested in your kingdom
and your cause in this life
and the life to come
grant him traveling mercies
future places that he's going to be
going to
i pray that you would continue to use
him for your glory and for your honor
may you place a hedge of protection
around him
may you continue to inspire him
and that
the words that he speaks would continue
to be not his own
but the words of life
may you continue to work in him both to
will and to do of your good pleasure for
we ask these things in the precious name
of jesus christ
amen
god bless you have a wonderful evening
[Music]
[Applause]
you